hey this is presto Walker how many
triangles are there in this figure this
is not just a puzzle to test your
observational skills this is actually a
common math test question in India I
learned about this problem from the
Indian Express this problem is actually
going viral because Bollywood
celebrities including Sonam Kapoor Aditi
Rao Hydari and diana penty were trying
to figure out the correct answer can you
figure it out give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching the
video and I'll explain the batha medical
way you can approach this problem so one
way you could solve this problem is by
counting every single triangle in the
figure this will be an exhaustive list
of all of the triangles if you're
careful you'll get the correct answer of
18 triangles but remember this is a
common test question in India and it
would be impossible for student to count
every single triangle and all the
different variations of this kind of
question on an exam so what is the
pattern in this question let's figure
out a mathematical way to count the
number of triangles we'll start by
focusing on a single figure if we have
one triangle there are no slanted lines
on the inside and we just have one big
triangle so this is easy we just have
one now what happens if we put a slanted
line on the interior of this triangle
how many total triangles are there well
we have the one big triangle from before
but we now have two more triangles we
have this small triangle and we have
another small triangle so when we have
one slanted line there are a total of
three which equals one plus two
triangles we have the one triangle from
before plus the two new triangles we've
created so what happens if we put
another slanted line on the inside well
we
still have the three triangles from
before we have the one big triangle we
have these two triangles from the one
slanted line case and now we've created
some new triangles we've created exactly
three smaller triangles from this new
line
so with two slanted lines on the
interior we have one plus two from the
one slanted line case plus we have added
three more triangles for total of one
plus two plus three which equals six
total triangles now there's another way
that you could count this if you list
all of these triangles you'll see that
we have three small triangles to medium
triangles and one large triangle this
also makes for total of six if we
continue this pattern we could guess the
general formula if you have n slanted
lines on the interior the total number
of triangles will be equal to one plus
two plus all the way going to n plus n
plus one and some of this will be n plus
one times the quantity n plus 2 all over
2 so how do we know this formula
actually holds well let's do a little
proof of this now let's add the two
slanted lines of the triangle these will
be the sides of the triangle so how many
slanted vertical lines are there well
there would be the N on the interior
plus the two vertical sides of the
triangle so there are a total of n plus
two vertical lines a triangle is formed
by any two of these slanted lines plus
the horizontal base of the triangle so
the total number of triangles will be n
plus 2 choose 2 and that simplifies to
be the quantity n plus 1 times the
quantity n plus 2 all over 2 so we
figured out a general way to count the
number of triangles in this kind of
shape so how does that help us solve the
original problem while this figure has a
total of 6 triangles now let's scale it
up a little bit by the same logic this
small figure also has a total of 6
triangles and this medium
also has a total of six triangles and if
we put them all together we've created
six plus six plus six triangles and you
can check we haven't created any other
triangles so the total of 80 triangles
did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
if you like this video please check out
my books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon if you have a math topic you can
email me pressure at mind your decisions
calm and you can catch me on social
media either at mind your decisions or
at pressure tell Walker